Hoi, ich bin der Sam von der Flüge Wings und wir schauen heute zusammen, dass das Thema Material kommt.
Es ist ein Thema, das Sie vielleicht schon etwas angeschaut haben im Theorie-Büchlein und auch schon Theorie-Fragen angeschaut haben und es sind relativ viele Fachbegriffe, Fremdwörter im Spiel.
Das sind Sachen, die man auswendig lernen muss, aber wir versuchen heute, all dem Ganze ein bisschen ins Gesicht zu geben, damit Sie hier einen Bezug haben und es einfacher zu lernen wird.
Was wir heute anschauen, ist, was gibt es überhaupt für Fluggeräte, dass Sie hier einen Hintergrund erfahren, wo es verschiedene Flug-Gleitschirme gibt, wo man auch verschiedene Sachen damit machen kann,
z.B. das hier beim Akrobatik-Gleitschirm bis zum Schuhell-Schirm.
Wie sobald der Gleitschirm aufgebaut ist, vom Material her schauen wir an, wir schauen die Kurzung an, wir schauen die Nordschirm an und wir schauen die Materialien hier dafür spezifisch an, ganz speziell auch die Gleitschirm-Linen,
weil dort noch relativ wichtig ist, dass wir ein bisschen wissen, wie das Ganze sich verhalten tut.
Wenn wir die Gleitschirm-Kategorien anschauen, haben wir einerseits den Schuhell-Schirm, das ist jetzt hier das Bild ganz im linken Eck, der weiss-rote, da sehen wir schon, das ist ein einfacher Schirm gebaut,
der ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig fest gestreckt, sondern er ist relativ kompakt und der Unterschied zum Schuhell-Schirm und einem Wettkampf-Schirm ist, dass ein Schuhell-Schirm gebaut ist,
damit er sicher ist, da ist Sicherheit absolut das Wichtigste, nicht so wichtig ist die Leistung. Unterkategoriert ist die Leistung wichtig
Dieser Flügel ist speziell für Hike'n'Fly gemacht,
damit man ein sehr kleines Packet hat,
mit ganz wenig Volumen und vor allem wenig Gewicht.
Und dann geht es zum Gegenteil,
sehr robust gebaut.
Auch das Bild ist der Akrobatikschirm,
wo man hier den Weissblau sieht,
damit man manöver mit dem Schirm fliegen kann,
der die extremsten Gehkräfte,
die extremsten Belastungen auf dem Schirm wirkt,
aber das Material hält,
richtig stark gebaut ist.
Und es gibt noch Kategorien von Speedgliedern,
wo man mit der Ski und ganz kleinen Schirmchen
đượcerflügt.
Auch das ist eine Form von Gliedschirmflügen,
allerdings eine andere Kategorie,
wo wir jetzt nicht genau darauf eingehen.
Das ganze Gliedschirmflügen ist auch eingestuft
in verschiedenen Homologationen.
Wir haben A, B, C und D.
Und wir sprechen vom Schuhschirm.
Das heisst, wie es hier steht,
dass die Passivsicherheit sehr hoch ist.
Schlussendlich ist die Idee,
dass wenn irgendeine Störung am Schuhschirm passiert
und der Pilot einfach loslässt,
dass der Schirm wieder von selbstständigem
Geradenausflug zurückkehrt.
Das wäre eigentlich der Wunsch,
den jeder Schuhschirm erfüllen müsste.
Jeder Konjunktur macht,
versucht möglichst, das anzukommen.
Und das haben wir heute in einem Bereich,
wo wir wirklich sagen können,
die fliegen sehr, sehr sicher
und wir haben auch schon eine relativ gute Leistung.
Leistung, als kleine Gedankenstütze
sprechen wir immer von Gleitleistung.
Das heisst, wenn wir z.B. von 1000m
bei ruhiger Luft starten
und einfach ins Tal fliegen,
kommen wir vielleicht mit einem Schuhschirm
8 km weit.
Mit einem Wettkampfschirm sind wir mittlerweile
etwa bei 12 km.
Hier ist schon eine Differenz,
aber 8 km ist schon sehr, sehr gut,
wenn wir vergleichen, dass wir vor wenigen Jahren
8 km sind und jetzt sind wir eher bei 8.
Oder sogar etwas darüber.
Dann geht es weiter mit dem B,
der Intermate-Schirm,
bei dem die meisten Piloten fliegen.
Nach dem Schuhschirm
haben wir schon ein paar Flüge gemacht.
Ich glaube, wir haben hoffentlich auch
ein paar Hundertflüge gemacht.
Zum B-Schirm geht es,
der auch noch eine passive Sicherheit hat.
Und der Pilot muss auch schon wissen,
dass er schnell auf eine Störung reagiert.
Beim C-Schirm, das umso mehr,
beimれた Wettkampfschirm,
ist das definitiv der Fall.
Hier verlangt es vom Pilot,
dass er sofort reagiert, dass er
nicht mehr überlegen muss was mache ich,
wenn die in diese Situation eintrifft.
Sondern dann muss er direkt im Tief reagieren,
ohne noch vorher gross zu überlegen,
was dann eigentlich los ist mit dem Schirm.
Wie kommt denn ein Schirm überhaupt
zu so einem A, B, C oder D?
Das Gürtelsiegel.
Das Gürtelsiegel ist mittlerweile
eigentlich die N-Norm.
Die N-Norm, die man antrifft,
ist weltweit gültig, aussen in Deutschland.
In Deutschland ist man nachher vor auf LTF,
das ist ehemalige DAV-Gürtelsiegel.
Das ist ein absolutes Detail, nicht wichtig.
Aber wir müssen wissen,
dass die deutschen Piloten
nur mit LTF-Briertengeräten fliegen.
Und sonst weltweit gilt die N-Gürtelsiegel.
Was wird dort gemacht?
Das wird einerseits der Schirm
mit einer Schockbelastung,
fest belastet,
nichts anderes als der Schirm an einem Fahrzeug,
das Fahrzeug fährt los
und das Seil hat eine Sohlbruchstelle drin,
die dann reisst
und nachher schaut man den Schirm an,
hat Schä của und darf keinen Schaden haben.
Wenn der Test erfolgreich war,
wird der Schirm nochmal eingespannt.
Das Auto
konjugierlich los,
beschleunigt immer mehr,
dass der Schirm, der hinten dran hängt,
auf 8G belastet wird.
8G ist das absolute Minimum.
Die heutige Schirmherstellung
ist eher bei 12 oder 16G.
Wenn wir den Akrobatikschirm nehmen,
sind wir sicher eher bei 16G.
Und auch dort wird dann nachher
der Brief angeschaut,
ist nichts kaputt gegangen,
sind alle Bauteile noch so, wie es sein sollte.
Das hat einen Gesamteindruck gemacht
und das alles protokolliert.
Was auch gemacht wird,
ist noch die Leinenfestigkeit geprüft,
sind die auch so, wie der Hersteller es angeht,
und Knickbriefungen folgt,
die der Hersteller vorgängig machen muss
und dass seine Leine, die er hier verbaut hat,
auch diese Belastung standhalten
und der richtige Faden verwenden wurde.
Das Ganze wird einem
Briefbericht festgehalten
und dann geht man weiter zum
Flugtest.
Der Flugtest ist zuerst ganz allgemein
wie sein Bremsweg.
Bei einem Wettkampfschirm sind Bremswege
von 0 bis 30 cm.
Bei einem Schulschirm sind sie eher
von 0 bis 60 cm.
Das kann relativ lang sein.
Das schaut man an.
Und nachher werden die Manöver geflogen.
Es werden 24 Manöver geflogen
mit dem Schirm.
Davon sind 90 Einzelpunkte,
die dann eben vergeben werden,
ist ein A-Schirm.
Wenn ein 9A hat, dann ist es ein A-Schirm.
Jeder hat wie das Airbnb-Schirm
und so werden die ganzen Punkte vergeben.
Das Ganze ist aber ein bisschen schwierig beim Gleitschirm,
weil es gibt kein Messverfahren dafür.
Das heisst, es ist schlussendlich im Augen des Betrachtes.
Es ist ein Experten, der unten ist.
Und der Test-Piloten in der Luft,
der beurdeit ist das Manöver jetzt ein A.
Oder eben ein B.
So, dass es,
Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede Jede.
Das ist etwas, was immer etwas kritisiert wird,
speziell von den Flugschulen.
Es wäre doch eher schöner,
wenn es sein müsste,
als Mehrheit drei Mal in das Manöver
hineinzupassend in die Kategorie
und vielleicht zweimal nicht bestehend.
Ein bisschen aussagekräftiger.
Aber auch so wichtig,
die Schirme, die wir haben,
ist schlussendlich unverzichtbar,
dass man Rote holt bei der Flugschule,
bei den Fluglehrern,
weil die kennen diese Schirme am besten.
Was wir überhaupt verbauen am Gleitschirm?
Grundsätzlich ist es ein Polyamid,
ein Nylon,
das Tuch ist.
Wir sehen es einerseits hier,
mit dieser Struktur drin,
die nennt man Ripstop.
Und zwar ist das nichts anderes
als eine Web-Technik,
in die Schuss erfolgt.
Und die sollte eigentlich verhindern,
dass das Tuch, wenn es mal ein Loch hat,
weiter reisst.
Das sind so wichtig.
Wenn es mal ein Loch hat, weiter reisst.
Das sind so wie kleine Barrieren im Tuch.
Und diese Barrieren sorgen dafür,
dass es nicht weiter reisst.
Aber man kann natürlich auch sehr dünne Stoffe
verwenden, die geringes Gewicht haben
und trotzdem sehr stabil sind.
Vor allem, wenn man es zieht.
Was nicht so gerne ist,
ist die Diagonalbelastung.
Dort ist eher mal ein Verzug drin.
Allerdings verbaut man sie genau so,
dass die Belastung möglichst aufs Tuch
sauber funktioniert.
Von einem Gleitschirm,
handelsübrigen Gleitschirm,
der nicht speziell auf Licht gemacht ist,
sind wir ungefähr auf 49 Gramm pro Quadratmeter.
Als Vergleich,
eine A4-Platte, die ich darauf schreibe,
hat 80 Gramm pro Quadratmeter.
Also sind wir dort schon sehr leichter.
Es geht aber noch viel leichter.
Nämlich mit 17 Gramm.
Dort sind wir im Lichtbaubereich
hergestellt.
Ein Schirm in Bau,
der vielleicht für Hike-and-Fly gemacht ist,
wenn wir ein bisschen mehr Packvolumen haben wollen,
sind wir noch bis 17 Gramm pro Quadratmeter.
Diese Zahl, bin ich sicher,
wird in Zukunft noch weit oben runtergehen.
Die Techniken werden vorgelaufen,
geforscht und gemacht.
Es ist natürlich ein Anlieger,
dass man einen Stoff hat, der gleich stabil ist
und noch leichter ist als das Ganze.
Was haben wir denn noch weiter für Materialien verbaut?
Wir haben den Schirm selber gelernt.
Das ist ein N உllons.
Ich sehe vielleicht auch in den Bergbahnen
diese Werbigen oben,
die man in den Gleitschirmen übertrieben sagt.
Schlussendlich ein Kunststoffmix,
das im Gleitschirm-Bereich
basiert.
Auch im Tragurt-Bereich,
Tochnora.
Von den Leinen kommen wir gerade dazu.
Wir haben
den Notschirm selber,
der aus einem Nylon ist.
Beim Notschirm selber ist es so,
dass es das gleiche Tuch ist.
Viel feiner gewebt.
Es ist noch dünner.
Erstens, beim Notschirm darf es
dehnen.
Es ist nicht so wichtig, dass er voll formstabil ist.
Gerade, wenn es eine Schlageöffnung gibt,
ist es wichtig, dass das Ganze sich bei den Leinen anfängt.
Aber auch beim Tuch.
Darum macht es dort weniger,
wenn das Tuch nicht ganz
so stabil ist.
Dazu kommen wir nachher noch schnell.
Was wir auch haben, sind Karabiner.
Wir haben einerseits Stahl und Aluminium auf dem Markt.
Hier scheiden sich
Geister. Lange Diskussion.
Der Aluminium hat
sicher etwas Nachteile bei mechanischen
Belastungen.
Auf einem Stein ist ein Aluminium sicher
schneller ein Deladin als bei einem Stahlkarabiner.
Allerdings halten sie
sehr, sehr lange
und gut.
Im allgemeinen Brauch sagt man,
dass man sie alle 5 Jahre wechseln sollte.
Der
Aluminiumkarabiner
bei Tests schneidet sogar ganz leicht besser ab.
Wenn man einen Test gemacht hat,
hat man ein paar Millimeter Spiel auf und zu machen lassen.
Und das ein paar tausend Mal
hat die Festigkeit
beim Aluminium besser.
Aber wir sprechen hier von Festigkeit,
die im normalen Gebrauch nicht
unterschritten wird.
Der Gleitschirm hat
Leine.
Das ist das, was auch entscheidend ist.
Mit dieser Leine kann man
viel machen, indem man Materialmix wählt.
Und man versucht,
die Besten herauszuholen.
Der Aluminiumkarabiner fliegt
so lange, wie er neu gebaut wurde.
Bei Anspruchungen gibt es da
irgendeinen Unterschied.
Gewisse Leine schrumpfen
und gewisse Leine dehnen.
Darum ist es wichtig, dort einen Supermix zu haben.
Wir fangen aber zuerst an,
beim Leinen Materialmantel.
Weil jede Leine,
die ummantelt ist,
ist letztendlich die Leine innen selber
und der Mantel rundherum.
Den Mantel machen wir aus ganz einfachen Gründen.
Vor allem die mechanische Belastung.
Wenn ich über einen Stein
oder die Leine untereinander reibe,
habe ich eine Schutzschicht drüber.
Das funktioniert sehr gut.
Und ich kann diese saubere Farbe trennen.
Bei Schuhschirmen haben wir oft
in der A-Bereiche rote,
und dann andere Farbe,
dass man von Anfang an den Anfänger sieht,
die Leine muss ich jetzt in die Hand nehmen
und farblich sauber trennt ist.
Das Ganze hat einen Nachteil,
dass die Leine viel dicker macht
und mit der Luftwiderstand
natürlich auch grösser ist.
Die Luftwiderstand ist etwas,
das wir gering halten.
Darum machen wir schlesendlich auch
die Leine, die nicht ummantelt sind,
die dann so ausgesend,
die kein Mantel haben.
Die haben natürlich auch wieder Vorteile,
dass wir eben rings Gewicht,
wenig Widerstand,
und verschiedene Material,
werden da auch verbaut.
Wir nehmen zuerst
das, was wir hier sehen.
Das ist Los Angeles Polyethylene,
ein Kunststoff.
Polyethylene
ist Los Angeles Polyethylene
und hat den grossen Vorteil,
dass sie sehr gut
im Festigkeitsverhältnis ist.
Sie ist leicht und hält sehr viel.
Die Aufhabenständigkeit ist hoch.
Die Alterung ist auch sehr gut
und man kann sie sehr gut verarbeiten.
Sie ist nicht ganz so sensibel,
wenn man nicht super
spitzig ist.
Mit dieser kannst du Relief gut nähen
und sie lässt sich gut bearbeiten.
Ein kleiner Nachteil hat sie,
dass sie bei der Belastung
beim Checken,
wenn man die Leine ausmesst,
und vor allem bei der Nichtbelastung
schrumpft.
Das heisst, wenn natürlich
der Gleitschirm fliegt,
hat er ungefähr 80
80% der ganze Belastung
auf A- und B-Ebene
und die restlichen 20%
sind die restlichen 20%.
Das heisst, wenn man
diese Leine verbaut
im C- und D-Bereich, wo sie kaum
belastet werden,
dann haben wir auch
bei 3-500 Gramm pro Leine
einen Schrumpf verdient.
Die andere, die auf dem Markt ist,
ist die Aramid-Leine.
Technora Kevlar,
der Markenname,
ist sehr langenstabil
und hat eine brünnliche Farbe.
Und dort ist ganz klar
der grosse Nachteil, dass sie
knickerempfindlich ist.
Wenn sie knickerempfindlich ist,
dann muss man gut darauf schauen,
wo man sie verbaut.
Wenn am Schirm ein Teil ist,
wo man sagt, dort wird sie
eher stark belastet,
dann ist es wichtig, dass sie dort
un-empfindlich ist
gegenüber dem Knicken
oder eben auch vor allem
die Längestabilität.
Deshalb ist es immer ein Mix zwischen
Aramid-Leine
und Dynema-Leine,
dass man vielleicht
im Bereich
einfach
den Mix
so hat, dass man ihn
im Griff hat.
Die Auffallbelastigkeit
ist ein Nachteil, darum
man sie oftmals vermanteln.
Oder wenn man sie nicht vermantelt,
kann man sie auch ein bisschen
einfärben, damit auch die farbliche
Training stattfindet.
Das ist die Kunst, dass man die
Unermantel so beschichten kann,
dass die Auffallbelastigkeit
sehr gut ist und funktioniert.